[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
surge in new covid cases is putting an
enormous strain on hospitals across the
country
at belleville medical center that's
outside houston texas patients needing
an icu bed are being airlifted to
hospitals in other states but finding an
open bed there is often difficult too
it's a struggle that can have life or
death consequences our lead national
correspondent that's david begno's in
belleville with more on this story david
good morning to you
good morning the next time you hear
somebody say that the covid crisis is
affecting non-coveted patients remember
the name daniel wilkinson he was a us
army veteran in fact the military flags
still fly right here on the front porch
of his home in belleville
he started feeling sick last weekend he
lives just an hour and a half down the
road from houston where they have some
of the best medical care in the world
and he lives within yelling distance of
the local hospital
but none of that was enough when he
started feeling sick and couldn't get
the medical care he needed
to survive
this was u.s army veteran daniel
wilkinson on an emergency room stretcher
shortly before he died he loved his
country he he served two deployments
over in afghanistan
came home with a purple heart
and it was a gall stone that took him
out
last saturday wilkinson's mother
michelle puget rushed him to belleville
medical center just three doors down
from their home
but for wilkinson help was still too far
away i do
labs on him i get labs and the labs come
back and i'm at the computer and i have
one of those
oh crap moments
er dr hassan cackley treated wilkinson
and he discovered that he had gallstone
pancreatitis something the belleville
hospital was not equipped to treat if
that stone doesn't spontaneously come
out and doesn't resolve itself
that fluid just builds up backs up into
the liver backs up into the pancreas and
starts to shut down those organs his
blood work even showed that his kidneys
were shutting down this went from
life-threatening to
he's dying in front of you yes
wilkinson needed a higher level of care
but with hospitals across texas and much
of the south overwhelmed with covet
patience
there was no place for him we're making
phone calls
sorry sorry sorry places had the
specialist to do the procedure but
because of how sick he was they didn't
have an icu bed to put him so then i'm
i'm at my computer and i'm just like
scratching my head i'm like and i get
this thought in my head i'm like what if
i put this on facebook or something
maybe someone can help out
one doc message me hey i'm in missouri
last time i checked we have icu beds we
can do this call call this number the
next guy messages me he's a gi
specialist he goes i'm in austin
i can do his procedure get him over to
me i said okay great let's go he texts
me back five minutes later
i'm sorry
i can't get administrative approval to
accept him we're full
for nearly seven hours
wilkinson waited in this bed i had that
thought
in my head is like i
need to get
his mother here
right now
i told her
i said
if he doesn't get this procedure done
he is going to die
i also had to have the the discussion
with him dan i said
if your heart stops in front of me right
here what do you want me to do
do you want me to do
everything we can to
resuscitate you and try and get your
heart back and i said if that were to
happen dan if i were to get you back
we're still in that position where we're
in right now what did he say he said i
want to talk to my mom about that
finally a bed opened up at the va
hospital in houston it was a helicopter
ride away he goes oh man i promised
myself after afghanistan i would never
be in a helicopter again
he goes oh well i guess
this is video of daniel being airlifted
to houston but it was too late they
weren't able to do the procedure on it
because it had been too long
and told me that they had seen air
pockets in his intestines which means
that they were already starting to die
off they told me that i had to make a
decision
and i knew how danny felt he didn't want
to be that way so we were all in
agreement that we had to let him go
roughly 24 hours after he walked into
the emergency room
daniel wilkinson died
at the age of 46. i've never
lost a patient from this diagnosis
never
because we know what needs to be done
and we know how to treat it and we get
them to where they need to go i'm scared
that the next patient that i see
is someone
that i can't get to where they need to
get to we are playing musical chairs
with a hundred people
and ten chairs when the music stops what
happens people from all over the world
come to houston to get medical care and
right now houston can't take care of
patients from the next town over that's
the reality
dr cackley says if we weren't in this
crisis it would have taken him 30
minutes to get daniel out the door it
took seven hours
there are 102 people in the houston area
waiting for an icu bed right now and i
called the county executive judge lena
hidalgo and i said judge can you not
open a field hospital and put these
people somewhere and she said david i
can and i'm ready but she said what i'm
hearing from the hospital executives are
we have more beds we just don't have the
nurses they got 700 nurses that arrived
in houston last week
and it's still not enough to meet the
demand
vlad
heartbreaking david bagno absolutely
heartbreaking thank you very much david
bagno and dr cackley really painted a
picture it's another part of the coveted
story that you don't often think about
the people that we're losing because
they're they don't have the the space
they don't have the personnel to treat
them and that's outrageous it's why it's
so important when people say
you should wear a mask you should show
solely distance or get vaccinated to get
a vaccine it's because it affects all of
us it's also why the death toll from
covet is not just the number of people
who die with the virus it's all those
people beyond it who are not getting the
help they need you survive a war
only to die in your own country because
of a gallstone for something that you
didn't have to exactly for something you
didn't have to die from all right david
thank you very much again